At some point growing up,
my vision changed.
And slowly I stopped being able
to see past about...
this far in front of my face.
Basically, anything past...
like 10 inches in front of my eyes...
is blurry.
So eventually I got glasses
and with them my world
turns from this...
to this.
This whole experience
as inconvenient as it is...
is more widespread than it's ever been.
[overlapping] “-Myopia.”
“-Myopia.”
[overlapping] “- Myopia, am I saying it right?”
“-A rise in short-sightedness...”
“...and the researchers actually
called it an epidemic...”
“...but they're still trying to figure out
why this is...”
Rates of myopia or
near-sightedness
or needing glasses to
see things far away...
have been rising for decades.
In the US, where I live
just 25% of people
were myopic in 1971.
By 2004, that number
was up to 42%.
And if current trends continue
it’s estimated that half of
the world's population
will be myopic by 2050.
In Hong Kong, Singapore,
Taiwan and South Korea
rates are already a lot
higher than that.
And a growing portion
have high myopia
which the WHO categorizes as
a prescription stronger than -5.
That puts them at risk of
losing their sight one day.
For decades,
researchers thought
that whether or not
you needed glasses
was just a matter
of genetics.
And it partly is.
Having one myopic parent
doubles your odds
of being nearsighted
and having 2 increases
the odds 5 fold.
But human genetics
don't change this fast.
The abruptness of this increase
suggests that
that this change
is environmental.
Something about the way
we live today
is making it harder
and harder
for people to see
at a distance.
So what could it be?
Most people are born
with eyes that are too short
from front to back.
In this shape, the lens focuses
images behind the retina.
That's the light sensitive tissue
at the back of the eye.
That makes the eye hyperopic
or farsighted.
Blurry up close and
clear from far away.
But as we grow up,
our eyes grow too.
Until they reach a spherical shape.
In this shape, the lens
focuses light directly
onto the retina and produces
a clear image.
But sometimes the eye
keeps growing longer.
In this shape, the lens can focus
up close images onto the retina.
But at a distance, images
focus at a point
in front of the retina...
making distance vision blurry.
So all of us with myopia
just have eyeballs that
have grown too long.
The eye does not look like
a basketball anymore.
It looks more like a rugby ball.
That's Seang Mei Saw.
She's a myopia epidemiologist
and physician in Singapore.
It is a lifelong disease
so once you're myopic,
it doesn't regress.
So what's making more and more
people’s eyes
grow longer than they should?
The evidence points to the way
we spend time in childhood
and adolescence.
That's when our eyes
grow fastest.
So it's when most people's
myopia develops
and then stabilizes.
Though it can develop later
if you abuse your vision enough.
Two factors in particular
have the biggest influence.
Near work or the time that we spend
looking at things up close...
and how much time we spend indoors.
In a healthy eye, muscles have to
squeeze the lens
in order to focus up close images
onto the retina.
So some experts theorize that
if your eyes grow up
straining to look at
things up close
a lot of the time, they'll
just grow longer
to reduce that strain.
But the evidence on this explanation
is mixed.
The stronger explanation
is time spent indoors.
Exposure to bright
outdoor light
stimulates the production of
dopamine in the retina.
This neurotransmitter regulates
the eyes growth...
without enough dopamine
the eye doesn't know when
to stop growing
and indoors it's hard
to get enough.
The light from the sun
has up to a 100,000 lux
on a sunny day.
Whereas in the room
the light levels generally
and only about 200 to 300 lux.
But between electronic devices
and early emphasis on academics...
eye experts believe that children today
are growing up with a combination
of too little daylight
and too much time doing
things up close.
And nowhere is that more apparent
than in East and Southeast Asia.
Children in Asia are not spending
that amount of time outside.
This could possibly be because
of the education system
has become much more competitive.
The children have a lot more work.
They attend teaching centers
and you spend more time
reading and writing.
Needing glasses or contacts
to see for the rest of your life
is obviously inconvenient.
But in the long term
the consequences of that
distorted eyeball shape
can become serious.
University of Houston
Professor of Optometry
Mark Bullimore, explained
this to me.
You know, you're born with a
finite amount of tissue
that make up the various coats
of your eyeball.
Excessive elongation of that
quite simply
places additional stress
on those structures.
The retina has been stretched
so much that starts to break
and then sort of peel off like
an old piece of paint.
The longer those eye structures
are stretched
the higher the risk
of disorders
like myopic macular degeneration,
retinal detachment...
glaucoma and cataracts.
So we're finding this almost
linear relationship between them.
The amount of myopia and
the risks to your vision...
later in life.
We used to think about myopia
as an optical defect.
Now we think about it
much more as a disease.
And the earlier a child
becomes myopic
the more serious their myopia
can become
and the greater the risk
of debilitating conditions.
Which means it's important to
intervene as early as possible.
So, what does that look like?
For those who start to develop myopia
there's treatment.
First are multifocal,
soft contacts, and glasses.
They make peripheral vision
intentionally blurry
which appears to slow the progression
of myopia.
Then there's orthokeratology
or ortho-k lenses...
hard contact lenses worn
only at night
that reshape the wearer's cornea
while they sleep...
so that they can see at a distance
during the day.
And there are atropine eye drops
low doses of a substance that
temporarily paralyzes
the eyes’ focusing muscles
which seems to reduce
the development of myopia.
But the first line of defense
is prevention.
The simplest and most effective way
to prevent myopia
is to get kids to spend
more time outside.
In Taiwan, the government introduced
a nationwide program in 2010,
encouraging schools
to get students outside for
2 hours every day.
It appears to have
successfully reversed
a 40 year-long increase
in myopia rates.
And since 2001
Singapore has funded public education
promoting time outdoors...
and conducted annual
vision screenings at schools.
And it seems
to be working.
Right now, these rates may be
higher than ever
but the future of myopia
will only look like this
if we keep doing things
the same way.
And we've never been in a better position
to change.